well we truly live in A Brave New World
well not really Brave anyway but it is
new I guess and it's new in ways that
threaten to make obsolete that old adage
that there's nothing new Under the Sun
because in our day and age we have many
we have managed to create some new
things I think things without precedent
things without historical analog
um the problem is that nearly all of
those things are well terrible take for
example the burgeoning industry of AI
pornography this is porn generated by
artificial intelligence it encompasses
both deep fake porn which is fashion to
look like some actual specific human
being and then totally artificial porn
whose images are created entirely by a
machine
um there's been a lot of discussion
about the subject this past week due to
a controversy in the world of twitch
streamers this is a world that remains
mostly foreign to me and perhaps to you
but I think we can both get the gist
from this write-up in Vice it says quote
on Monday twitch streamer Brandon Ewing
who goes by atriac online admitted to
buying and watching deep fakes from an
account that makes non-consensual
sexually explicit AI generated videos of
his colleagues in the streaming World in
a live stream on Monday Ewing
inadvertently showed browser windows
open to a website that hosts
non-consensual AI generated images the
window showed that he was viewing images
on the account of someone who
specialized in making deep fakes of
popular streamers viewers of the stream
caught the leak and screenshotted the
site and shared the site images from it
and names of the women who were deep
faked at first reported by Dextero Ewing
said during his Monday stream in a
tearful now viral apology that he
clicked an ad for deep fake porn while
browsing PornHub that ad took him to
another subscriber only website that he
said were paid to view the images of
popular female streamers he said that he
was driven by morbid curiosity that his
watching non-consensual porn is not a
pattern of behavior
his wife cosplayer Ariana Ewing I don't
know what any of these words mean sat in
the background of the stream and cried
uh
here's some of whatever that is
stream to like create a pattern of
behavior where I really want especially
women on Twitter to feel safer like I uh
we call buba spam cringe we don't do
that there I've never made like a
weird I don't know sea sniffing joke
I've never done anything like that I've
never done anything like that on the
stream and we don't tolerate any sex
behavior in the chat we ban it on site
and uh and like I've done this
consistently over and over and over and
then at 2 am
you know I've been watching so much I've
been reading so much AI stuff uh
reading all this stuff about Ai and and
uh
defect music and everything and I'm in
these discords and I was I feel so
embarrassing to me but I was on
website and there was an ad there's an
ad on every video for this so I know
other people must be clicking it because
it's on every video
now to me the I the the real problem one
of the real problems here is that this
guy is a professional I mean he's a
professional broadcaster this is what
qualifies as professional broadcasters
these days he has a large audience
people who sit around and watch him and
listen to him and yet he's incapable of
stringing three words together without
an F-bomb I mean he has the rhetorical
skill of like a college freshman it just
downed three beer bongs and yet he has
320 000 followers on a streaming
platform
that to me is uh the issue or it's an
issue the bigger problem of course is
the AR I AI porn itself and some have
made an attempt to defend this guy
claiming that well he isn't hurting
anyone by watching deep fake porn
but of course any rational and uh even
just nominally decent person understands
that using someone's image without their
permission using their face their
likeness to create pornography is a
moral Abomination and consuming such
pornography knowing how it was created
is also morally abominable yet whether
deep fakes or other forms of AI point
the trend is becoming so prevalent so
fast that internet platforms are
scrambling to figure out how to handle
all this this is uh just a couple weeks
ago in the New York Post this article
says the internet group that creates
pornographic images using artificial
intelligence was kicked off fundraising
platforms Kickstarter and patreon after
raising nearly sixty thousand dollars
following complaints from social media
users unstable diffusion describes
itself as an online community of artists
dedicated to creation and sharing of AI
generated NSFW not suitable for word
content
um the group uses open source text to
image generating systems that were
popularized by online groups such as
stable diffusion and dance diffusion
last year the AI powered technology doll
e which generates digital images from
text descriptions took the Internet by
storm
um quote unstable diffusion is a group
dedicated to spreading free and
expressive AI usage born out of a
Grassroots Community effort to reject
the limiting rules of corporate AI
companies the group says on its website
AI porn has become it's become a point
of debate on Twitter as well this week
where an image of four blonde women went
viral because people were arguing about
whether the image was AI or not
um here's a photo it's a blurred photo
because women are mostly naked but here
it is and I I think that this is AI
based on the fact that the faces all
look creepily the same but the fact that
we can't tell for sure
that there's any debate about whether
the women in that image actually exist
is precisely what makes this so
terrifying because we are rapidly
getting to a point
we've already reached the point probably
where you simply cannot be sure whether
an image a voice even a video that you
watch is real or not even if it features
someone who you know exists
that doesn't mean that it actually is
real
this new reality or unreality has
far-reaching implications that I don't
think I don't think we've even begun to
scratch the surface of but those
implications are perhaps the most
disturbing in this realm in the realm of
porn
um now some real Flesh and Blood
internet prostitutes like only fans
model Laura Lux have spoken out about
the possibility that the entire porn and
cyber prostitution industry will soon
come crashing down as the people in that
field can all now be replaced by
artificial intelligence uh luck says
that she's not worried about that
however because as she tweeted quote
anyone who thinks AI generated images of
hot naked women is going to ruin the
only fans economy for real life women
has a fundamental misunderstanding of
what only fans is people don't subscribe
to my only fans because they want to see
a random naked woman they subscribe to
my only fans because they want to see me
naked specifically based on a parasocial
connection formed by following me on
other social media platforms
now I'm not really
I confess concerned about the job
security of only fans prostitutes when I
mentioned the horrific implications of
this technology that's not exactly what
I was talking about in fact if anything
putting porn stars out of work is maybe
the one single benefit of this
technology because at least it might
Force these women's to to these women to
do something productive and valuable
with their lives instead
and
I do think that day is coming because
despite the um the reassurance Miss Lux
offers to us but really to herself
there's a reality here which is that you
know she's correct that only fans
customers
are looking for something that resembles
a human connection human affection
Romance
it's just that the porn consumer has
given up on finding the genuine thing
and instead settles for its digital
imitation
that's precisely the problem for Miss
Lux they've already decided to Forfeit
genuine human Connections in favor of an
image on a screen they choose you as the
only fans model because you're not real
to them
you're not human to them you you are
accessible you are usable reusable you
are an object that they can make use of
and then discard until they want you
again you are a masturbatory aide you
are to them
nothing but a collection of body parts
you're not a human being to them you you
have been dehumanized and you are taking
part in your own dehumanization
you might as well already be a robot
which means that you can easily be
replaced by robot and as far as the porn
consumer is concerned nothing at all
would be lost
that's the harsh truth
and this is the fear with AI opponents
it's the same fear with regular porn
actually only accelerated once
artificial intelligence is added into
the mix
because increasingly people are
rejecting
human connection Human Relationships
human romance and all that traditionally
comes with it including marriage and
family in favor of images on a screen
and this is dehumanizing not just to the
person on the screen unless that person
is already not human but also
dehumanizing to the consumer
and that's also why our criticism of
um of the porn industry cannot focus
just on the fact that the porn industry
is fueled by sex trafficking for example
and that is a major problem it's not the
only problem with porn just as our
criticism of AI porn cannot focus just
on the fact that people are often being
used in deep fakes without their consent
that's a major problem with that
technology but it's not the only problem
with it
in both cases we cannot neglect to
acknowledge
the harm that's also done to the
consumer
as the consumer the viewer is driven
further into self-isolation cut off from
meaningful relationships
and destroying the ones that he already
has
while spending his time ingesting
depraved filth
he is uh lessened by it made into a
smaller
less happy less interesting less
productive all-around less impressive
and fulfilled person
and now with AI adding fuel to the fire
the situation is only going to go from
bad to worse
unless we do something
[Music]
[Applause]